[Music]
the return of one of the most famous big
monsters um ever is just one of the five
picks to help you crush your viewing
schedule this week along with that other
monster not named King Kong we're
bringing you Beyonce in movie form Oscar
Winters Natalie Portman and Julian Moore
sharing the screen a Christmas themed
action thriller and the return of
everyone's favorite group of
dysfunctional MI5 agents it's all coming
up on this week's what to
watch
smashing its way in US theaters is the
film Godzilla minus one the biggest
reason to check this one out pun
intended is the fact that this marks the
37th overall film in the Godzilla
franchise one that's been going strong
for 70 years 70 dang another reason to
consider this one is that if you haven't
already you'll be discovering one of the
most groundbreaking filmmakers in the
Japanese movie industry inashi yamazaki
who wrote directed and did the visual
effects for this one talk about a triple
threat plus this movie about a giant
monster emerging in post-war Japan has
already become a box office hit in Japan
and so far at least is one of the series
highest rated films on the Tomato Meter
simply put people saw it people liked it
I know that all of my struggle and
sacrifice is opening the door for the
next also in theaters is a documentary
concert offering called Renaissance a
film by Beyonce how's this for a reason
to enjoy this movie it's Queen baay a
cultural icon and one of the top selling
music artists of all time with over 200
million records sold worldwide she has
32 Grammys the most won by any artist to
go with 26 VMAs 24 NAACP image Awards
and so on you get it the second reason
to check this one out is that Beyonce
seriously knows how to do it if her 2019
certified fresh film homecoming is any
indication cuz it's more than just a
concert as this one will cover the
creation of the Renaissance album and
accompanying Visual Album along with
develop in and putting on the Epic World
Tour to go with it all it's the full
package in other words reason three is
that the album that this is all based on
Renaissance was a huge hit it contained
the Platinum single break my soul and it
debuted at number one making Beyonce the
first female artist to have her first
seven albums debut at number one seven
like what we're so happy to have you
thank you for doing this it's so
generous well I want you to tell the
story right don't I premiering on
Netflix this week is the romance drama
film May December look no further than
the two main stars of this one for the
first reason to check it out I'm talking
Oscar winners Natalie Portman and
Julianne Moore together on the same
screen enough said reason too that may
December will make your month even
better is the Intriguing premise which
is Loosely based on the story of Mary
Kay Leo in it Portman plays an actress
who is studying the life of a
controversial woman she is going to
portray played by Moore who is Infamous
for a marriage that began when her
husband was a minor thirdly this film
hit theaters for short run before moving
on to Netflix and is sporting a very
high audience score to go along with
being a certified fresh hit with critics
in fact the critics consensus Praises
its campy humor and calls it a
seductively discomforting
[Music]
watch shots fired shots fired all units
please
respond also tiptoeing in the theaters
is a holiday action thriller Silent
Night the first reason to watch this one
is that it literally puts the silent in
silent night as in the film contains
hardly any dialogue at all while it
follows a grieving father who is getting
some much needed revenge against a gang
on Christmas Eve and that father is
played by Joel kinaman the film star and
the second reason to get loud for silent
night he was great in AMC's The Killing
a mustat if you haven't already and has
since done his thing in projects like
House of Cards Suicide Squad and For All
Mankind the third reason to give this
one a shot is that it marks the return
of John Woo with his first American
feature in 20 years series he's of
course the genius behind action Classics
like hard target faceof and Mission
impossible to among others I know it's
not easy being banished from MI5 to my
department but that's on you also
premiering this week is season 3 of the
popular Apple TV Plus show slow horses
this spy Thriller Stars the Gary Oldman
as a skilled yet obnoxious and let's
face it drunk leader of A Dysfunctional
team of MI5 agents that premise and
Oldman himself pair up for a great first
reason to discover this show a second is
that it's based on the popular slow
housee series of mystery thriller novels
by Mick Heron which follow the Jackson
lamb character so brilliantly played by
Oldman how do I know his performance is
brilliant the critics told me slow
horses already has two certified fresh
Seasons under its saddle including
season 2 sitting 100% on the Tomato
Meter and along with praising oldman's
performance critics credit the series
for refreshing the Espionage genre okay
that's it five picks a kick your
December off the right way be sure to
let us and your fellow viewers know in
the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rot tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay
fresh